told the coronavirus is taking in this
nation and around the world but while
pandemics like this one have claimed
millions of lives one vector of disease
has an even more fearsome record it's
the tiny mosquito the story is detailed
in the recent book the mosquito a human
history of our deadliest predator and as
author Timothy winegar tells us this
dangerous pest has not only affected our
health but our history before covin 19
she was the villain transferring
diseases frontline healthcare workers
sought to annihilate the mosquitoes
mosquitoes the mosquito mosquitoes the
mighty mosquito infects tens of
thousands each year last summer we
traveled to mérida Mexico south of the
border to see one of those preemptive
strikes in action how bad would
mosquitoes see resumes can almost become
famous I'm telling through them they
have fever when they advise them that's
one of the signs of dengue fever
survivor Maria del Sol Lupe is on the
offensive
allowing indoor insecticide spraying in
her home it's an innovative approach in
the war on mosquitoes we can have a
reduction of over 70% in the number of
mosquitoes for up to six months
four times more effective than aerial
spraying says Professor Gonzales Vasquez
proko Peck who's part of a team from
Emory University that's allied with
scientists from the Autonomous
University of the Yucatan why is this
important to people in the United States
we have the mosquitoes in the US so the
more we know about methods that can
control them more applicable they might
become is this mosquito territory 110
trillion of them at any given time
historian Timothy Weingard author of the
book the mosquito is fascinated by the
bug especially the female because she's
the one who bites and transmits disease
he says we weren't her only prey 70% of
dinosaur species regionally were either
extinct or endangered by the time the
meteor crashes into the Yucatan
Peninsula come on you're saying that the
dinosaur was endangered by the mosquito
certain dinosaur species were certainly
either already extinct or endangered
from mosquito-borne and sandfly borne
diseases but Weingard says putting man's
relationship with the mosquito into
context is even more mind-blowing she
was far more lethal than the minds of
the most brilliant generals or man-made
weapons disease up until the second
world war took 65 percent of deaths on
the battlefield think of that Caesar
Hannibal Genghis Khan the Crusaders and
every invasion migration and conflict so
depending on immunity or where the wars
were fought one side usually benefited
from her destruction of the other side
and she I mean decided that the fate of
empires and nations and countless Wars
and certainly from Alexander all the way
to the Second World War
mosquitoes likely hitched a ride aboard
the Nina Pinta and Santa Maria and
thousands of slave ships that
transported human cargo across the
Atlantic they very quickly started
vectoring malaria and other diseases and
Africans had an immunity
right which is partly why they became
such a lucrative commodity on the
plantation systems European indentured
servants or workers were dying in droves
of mosquito-borne disease then there's
the American Revolution the forces of
generals Washington and Lafayette didn't
do it by themselves they had a little
they had a lot of help
Cornwallis says very clearly to his
commander General Clinton and also in
his diary that this surrender was not
caused by anything you know the
Americans are French did but because he
had roughly 35 percent of his troops
available to fight because they were
absolutely shredded by malaria so the
birth of our nation we owe to the
mosquitoes indeed she is a founding
mother of the United States still she
played millions of Americans from the
end of the 17th century to the beginning
of the 20th with malaria and yellow
fever the death toll from yellow fever
alone was more than a hundred thousand
the CDC was established in 1946 and at
that time I was known as the
communicable disease Center and before
that the office of malaria Control says
CDC research entomologist dr. John
gymnic its mission was to protect US
troops and the government even enlisted
the likes of Theodor Seuss Geisel better
known as dr. Seuss along with Walt
Disney and his Seven Dwarves
[Music]
by the mid-1950s the u.s. curbed the
spread of most mosquito-borne illnesses
DDT our main weapon of choice though
highly effective it was discontinued in
part for polluting the environment
impossible links to cancer gimmicks says
now the highly adaptable predator is
back on the hunt and gaining ground
so we're monitoring to make sure that
they remain susceptible to the the
chemicals that we apply and then of
course we want to look for new tools and
as she expands her range across the
planet human defense is moving to what
some describe as a form of biological
warfare scientist Abdul Martin Park is
raising male mosquitoes infected with
the bacteria called Baba Kea that
effectively sterilizes them you need a
wild mosquito a female yeah to mate with
the infected mosquito some have already
questioned the ethics of such approaches
which include going even further
altering the DNA of the insect to
inhibit its ability to transmit disease
it's all on the mind of scientists like
Professor Vasquez pro Quebec who are
leading the charge will there be a day
that we won't have these epidemics
anymore we hope so that's in a way the
goal that all of us the scientists have
to have a positive benefit in a world in
which we might still have some
circulation of these pathogens but the
harm they produce would be so minimum
that we won't have to worry about it so
much of what we've done to eradicate
some of those mosquito-borne illnesses
are certainly being looked at in the
process and now context is everything in
our fight against Corona but it's really
interesting to see how history is
influenced by disease yeah and we will
be talking about this one
you're right Michele and even more
interesting to hear about all of that
especially in this time the cry of
Playball has finally run out